President Trump is facing sharp
criticism for granting a pardon to Joe
Arpaio the former sheriff of Maricopa
County Arizona Arpaio gained notoriety
for his aggressive action to arrest
illegal immigrants the pardon was
granted just hours before hurricane
Harvey made landfall lawmakers and civil
rights advocates are questioning the
president's decision and its timing to
clear up Arpaio of a criminal contempt
charge and possible jail time
Arpaio was scheduled to be sentenced in
October
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
more this morning Erol good morning good
morning while the pardon itself comes as
no surprise Democrat and Republican
senators as well as a few civil rights
organizations are all slamming president
Trump's decision one group going as far
as to call the move a defense of racism
but Sheriff Joe can feel good president
Trump alluded to his impending pardon at
a campaign star rally in Phoenix on
Tuesday do the people in this room like
Sheriff Joe was Sheriff Joe convicted
for doing his job
Arpaio who called himself America's
toughest sheriff was convicted of
criminal contempt last month for defying
a judge's order to stop detaining people
solely on the suspicion that they were
in the country illegally it was a
practice that was widely criticized as
racially profiling Latinos in a White
House statement President Trump
applauded Arpaio for quote his life's
work protecting the public from the
scourges of crime and illegal
immigration and said after more than 50
years of admirable service to our nation
he is worthy of a presidential pardon
CBS News has learned that pardon was
driven by the White House and did not
follow typical Department of Justice
guidelines it requires at least a
five-year threshold before the agency
can review a clemency petition the
Department of Justice has said the
president exercised his lawful authority
and we respect his decision the former
sheriff thanked the President and said
he will hold a news conference next week
to tell his side of the story pardon or
no pardon I'll be with him to the
and I say that I'll have more to speak
out and that the true story come out
about the abuse of the judicial system
and politics the decision has outraged
civil rights organizations like the ACLU
it called the pardon and endorsement of
racism and that by pardoning Arpaio
quote Trump has chosen lawlessness over
justice division over unity hurt over
healing now Arizona's Republican
senators John McCain and Jeff Flake have
both denounced president Trump's
decision and all of this happened while
staff at the White House for dealing
with yet another staff shake-up it was
announced on Friday the president's
deputy assistant Sebastian Gorka is no
longer with the administration
one official explaining that Gawker did
not resign Dana
another busy night at the White House
Errol Barnett thank you